we are in charge of making sure that the
leaders and it's killer the President of
the European Council that all the
support they need in terms of media work
this means organizing the press
conference is this means organizing all
the audio/visual work the hosts
broadcast coverage this means also
briefing journalists on the substance of
the talks this means delivering to them
the information in terms of the
conclusions the press release is needed
and these needs also troubleshooting and
fixing a thousand thousand problems that
arise in the situation like this where
you have 1500 journalists in the ypres
center plus hundreds of delegation I am
the press officer responsible for the
justice and Home Affairs Council here we
are with the hectic preparations of the
justice and Home Affairs Council that we
took place this week at the end of the
week so we have prepared a document a
background briefing note for the
journalists so it's a document they may
use to write all the articles before the
council in a few minutes we will hold a
technical briefing and then they can ask
questions to the ambassador of the
residency and also we will help them to
understand what are the main issues at
stake in this meeting my name is
Alexandra I kalencom and I coordinate
social media for the council we use
social media to communicate about our
work to answer questions and to monitor
emerging new stories and hot topics on
Twitter we're currently active on
Twitter Facebook YouTube and will
probably be branching out into Google+
as well
welcome to the media monitoring
department we monitor the news in order
to be able to compile press reviews for
example this is one of ours it is a
compilation of all the articles of the
daily news from the main newspapers but
also in order to provide media in-depth
analysis for users for example the press
summary which gives a summary of the hot
topics of the day but we also write
media intelligence reports for example
this one that focuses on one specific
topic we mainly cover the written press
but our outcome has become almost
exclusively digital our role as the
press center is to organize all the
press events taking place here in the
council building this goes from press
conferences doorsteps at the VIP
entrance and of course all the
activities of the President of the
European Council and we also try to
ensure good working conditions for the
press whenever they come to the council
building this goes from organizing
workspace as this one here and providing
technical equipment such as Wi-Fi signal
is no demand to Jos a sample database a
concertina County the Sun get a biggie
key francophone surprise can you share
data yeah well haciendo tarea de pavo Oh
Cody yahuveh physiol shows on Sheila
proceed on wilshire may santa paula
nanakuli kinsella on a la foto estudio
de groupe de travail la ceiba effete
what we are doing here with the
audiovisual team of the council is that
we are responsible for covering all the
public part of the events that are
happening here which means concretely
that we are everywhere with cameras
we're with photographers we capture the
right moments we digitize everything and
we upload it on a platform that we call
TV new school and all these people here
behind me they are actively working now
on uploading all the material that we
have been filming today in order for
journalists to be able to download the
material very quickly and to republish
it on their channels or their platforms
and we try to do that really in no type